da sind wir wieder am Ende einer Woche
voller Vorfreude und Träumen gemeinsam
vom best Case-Szenario also einer Welt
in der Vladimir Putin und Donald Trump
im Knast sitzen
gern auch in derselben Zelle wenn sich
es ergibt wäre das schön
die beiden alten Kumpels die 2016
zusammen die US-Wahl gewonnen haben
Trump hat seine Verhaftung sogar selber
angekündigt für letzten Dienstag ich saß
wirklich den ganzen Tag mit Popcorn vom
Fernseher nichts ist passiert zwei
Anklagen stehen angeblich bevor in New
York wegen Trumps schweige Geldzahlung
an die legendäre Pornodarstellerin
stormy Daniels und in Georgia weil er
2020 in einem Telefonat den Wahlleiter
aufgefordert hat für ihn mal eben 11000
Stimmen zu finden
oder ein Trumps Worten die perfect
Georgia
oder die stormy horse face Daniels
excortion
Pferdegesicht sagt das Hamster hören
über eine Frau mit der er doch was hatte
welche Ironie liebe Zuschauer Trump hat
zum capitolsturm also einem Umsturz
aufgerufen und stolpert jetzt vielleicht
über das schweige Geld für stormy
Daniels sollte sie am Ende die
amerikanische Demokratie retten braucht
es eigentlich eine neue Freiheitsstatue
oder mindestens
mindestens dann spielt sie quasi in
einer Liga mit Abraham Lincoln so was
ist aber was ist dran an den schweige
Geld Vorwürfen gar nichts sagen sie bei
Fox News und bestreiten sogar das intime
Verhältnis an sich mit echt schlüssigen
Argumenten
ja logisch einfach zählen wie viel
Kinder man hat dann weiß man genau wie
oft man Sex hatte
scheiße
kann frau Daniels Trumps come back noch
stoppen nicht dass es dem Fall jetzt
juristisch helfen würde aber ein
Interviews hat sie zu Protokoll gegeben
der Penis des Ex-Präsidenten sehe aus
wie die Figur tot aus Mario Kart
nicht weiter drüber nachdenken es ist
das es ist das Tor zur Hölle wirklich
übrigens nach amerikanischem Recht
dürfte Trump sogar aus dem Knast raus
Wahlkampf machen das ginge und bitte
nicht vergessen der Mann hat trotz allem
immer noch viele Fans Unterstützung für
Trump kommt aus Russland der ehemalige
Präsident mit wer der ruft die
Amerikaner zum Bürgerkrieg auf holt euch
das Land zurück Amerikaner in den Kampf
heißt es auf seinem Telegramm Kanal ja
das kommt davon wenn man wegen der
Sanktion den ganzen Wodka selber säuft
ne der Irre mit venef droht außerdem dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof in Den
Haag mit Raketen Beschuss wegen des
Haftbefehls für Vladimir Putin der
wiederum macht als Antwort erstmal eine
spontane Spritztour durchs von ihm
zerstörte mariopol zynischer wird's
nicht aber was ist der Haftbefehl Wert
Marco Buschmann unser Justizminister hat
gerade erst der Bild am Sonntag verraten
wenn Putin deutschen Boden betritt würde
er Zitat direkt verhaftet gut das klingt
erstmal ein bisschen großmäulig aber
tatsächlich gibt es das schon ein sehr
konkreten Plan und der geht so am 7
April hat Gerd Schröder Geburtstag und
natürlich wird da ein sehr schlecht
verkleideter Putin nach Hannover fliegen
Ehrengast auf der Party vom Gazprom Gerd
ausgelassene Stimmung aber dann reißt
sich plötzlich Frau Schröder Kim die
Maske runter wie bei Mission Impossible
und ist in Wirklichkeit Marco Buschmann
der die letzten 5 Jahre undercover als
Frau von Gerd Schröder gelebt hat genial
so geht ein Satz meine Damen und Herren
ja der Haftbefehl konkret verhängt wegen
der Verschleppung von Kindern aus der
Ukraine ist natürlich völlig richtig
also als Signal als Symbol vollstrecken
wird ihn wohl in nächster Zeit leider
keiner hier Reaktion direkt aus dem
russischen Propaganda Bunker
jedes Land das überhaupt so etwas wagt
wie dieser deutsche Drecksack
Justizminister oder was auch immer der
ist zu sagen dass er das umsetzen möchte
die müssen wissen jeder versucht das
auszuführen ist eine Kriegserklärung die
einen sofortigen Nuklearschlag zufolge
hat
Alter die russische Anne Will ist ja
voll Agro
übrigens wenn Putin wirklich mal nach
Deutschland kommt weil er weiß ich nicht
ins Phantasialand will oder so dann
sollten ihn aber bitte auch hier vor
Gericht stellen Freunde es war ernsthaft
wir haben doch für sowas ohne Ende gutes
Personal sehr schön so also beschäftigen
wir uns wieder mit
einander sie sprechen jetzt von Notwehr
und nächste Woche bei Richterin Barbara
Salesch der Prozess gegen Donald Trump
und eine gerichtszeichnerin verzweifelt
weil sie nicht genug orangene Buntstifte
dabei hat
wird eine Highlight Folge Barbara
Salesch versus Putin ja aber machen wir
uns bitte nichts vor putin ist
international nicht ansatzweise so
isoliert wie der Westen das gerne hätte
Präsident Shiva gerade drei Tage in
Moskau ja und Putin haben sich da BFF
Tattoos stechen lassen
viele Länder machen gar nicht mit bei
unseren Sanktionen unter anderem aus dem
globalen Süden wo man vor allem die
Rolle der USA kritisch sieht wo den
Menschen ja ich sag mal gewisse
Widersprüche auffallen wenn Präsident
beiden über den putinhaft Befehl spricht
das ist gerechtfertigt aber der
Gerichtshof ist nicht international
anerkannt auch nicht von uns aber es
sendet ein sehr starkes Signal
wir machen nicht mit bei eurem
Völkerrecht Bullshit aber auf Putin
dürfte das gerne anwenden
2020 haben die USA sogar mal Sanktionen
gegen den Haag verhängt bei deren
Ankläger ist gewagt hatten gegen US
Soldaten zu ermitteln nach
Kriegsverbrechen Olaf Scholz begrüßt
übrigens auch den Haftbefehl gegen Putin
Zitat des Kanzlers niemand steht über
Recht und Gesetz
grundsätzlich sehr wichtig was die
konsequente Anwendung in der Praxis
angeht naja aber das Verhandeln wir
jetzt
das heute-show heuchelgericht mit
Richter Oliver Welke
diese Applaus war eindeutig gehäuchelt
so meine Damen und Herren wir verhandeln
heute gegen Vladimir einmarschirowitsch
Putin das Wort hat Albrecht Humboldt
laut Stiftung Warentest Deutschlands
schlechtester Pflichtverteidiger
zum dritten Mal in Folge toll
euer Ernst Herr Putin lässt sich
entschuldigen er wäre gerne persönlich
gekommen aber er kriegt heute einen DHL
Paket und muss zu Hause sein außerdem
dieser haftbefehl ist eine Farce mein
Mann dann ist international noch immer
hoch angesehen Frage würde der
chinesische Präsident zu Fuß aus China
über einen 6000 km langen roten Teppich
bis nach Moskau Latschen für einen
Verbrecher nein hier stoßen sie an mit
dem traditionellen Spruch wer nicht
trinkt der ist ja
mir ist langweilig kommen Sie zum Punkt
mein Punkt ist wenn unser Kronzeuge
wenn unser Kronzeuge dieser windige
Hamburger hafenverkäufer sagt niemand
steht über dem Gesetz dann muss ich
schon fragen was ist denn mit ihm hier
Sekunde noch
ihm hier
Ex-Präsident Busch wann muss der sich
denn verantworten genau 20 Jahre nach
dem Irakkrieg ein Spruch
und ich sagen will
Opa Busch hat neulich aus Versehen alles
zugegeben in einer Rede über Putins
Invasion
[Gelächter]
ich liebe sein Gesicht wenn er merkt
dass er Irak gesagt ja
erfundene Massenvernichtungswaffen
hunderttausende tote aber keine Anklage
weil die USA nicht mitmachen in der Haag
ja gut der Anwalt aber nichts davon
macht irgendwas besser an Putins
Angriffskrieg gut dann rufe ich ihn hier
in den Zeugenstand
Prinz Binz Heilmann von Saudi Arabien
führt seit Jahren einen
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg im Jemen
außerdem hat er den Journalisten kashogi
umbringen lassen und das hier ist die
gerechte Strafe durch Olaf Scholz
die Ampelkoalition genehmigt wie schon
die Vorgängerregierungen Rüstungsexporte
an Saudi Arabien
Sanktionen mal anders trotz
Exportbeschränkungen schicken wir den
Prinzen im letzten Jahr Rüstungsgüter
für über 44 Millionen aha aber wie passt
das bitte zur wertebasierten
Außenpolitik
Moment da möchte ich kurz nachfragen
mein mann kann sich nicht erinnern
[Applaus]
niemand steht unter dem Gesetz außer die
die keinen Bock drauf haben die Sitzung
ist geschlossen die Kosten des
Verfahrens trägt wie immer der
Gebührenzahler
so meine Damen und Herren keine Ahnung
wie es Ihnen geht aber mir geht der
retrowan langsam auf die Nerven der
Kalte Krieg kommt zurück das Glücksrad
und jetzt auch noch die Bankenkrise mein
Gott Europa ist gerade wirklich so knapp
am Nächsten lieben Moment
vorbeigeschrammt meiner wäre die Credit
Suisse zweitgrößte Bank der Schweiz wie
sagt man banketti gewesen
wie konnte das noch mal so spannend
werden die große Lehre aus der letzten
Finanzkrise war doch angeblich nie
wieder Banken mit Steuergerät Rennen ja
ist denn heute schon wieder 2018
offensichtlich ja inklusive der greatest
beruhigungs-hits Sparguthaben in
Deutschland sind nach wie vor sicher da
kann man in Warnung geben das Geld ist
sicher ihre Einlagen sind sicher
insofern ist das wirklich kein Grund
dass sich irgendjemand hier in
Deutschland große Sorgen machen muss
[Applaus]
ja ich sag mal so die Vertrauenskrise
ist noch nicht vorbei Freunde die
Vertrauenskrise ist noch nicht vorbei
heute ist zum Beispiel die Aktie der
Deutschen Bank aber mal sowas von
abgerauscht und nicht nur die und seit
dem letzten Wochenende wissen wir
offiziell dass Banken immer noch starten
erpressen können da hilft es wenig da
ist sogar kontraproduktiv dass die
Kredit Suisse durch eine Zwangsehe mit
der UBS gerettet wird die beiden größten
Schweizer Banken
zusammengenäht zu einem absoluten
Monster ist nicht übertrieben die
Bilanzsumme dieser neuen mega-bank ist
doppelt so hoch wie das Schweizer
Bruttoinlandsprodukt
das heißt wenn die über die Wupper geht
gibt es in der Schweiz wirklich nur noch
ein paar Berge und die Bobo das war's ne
ja von wegen nie wieder zu big to fail
man fragt sich warum machen wir Menschen
die selben Fehler immer und immer wieder
immer dieselben
uns ein diesmal klappt
das ist gemein herzlichen Glückwunsch
auch von mir
klar ist die Schweiz ist ab jetzt noch
erpressbarer durch die neue riesen UBS
was ist denn da los in dieser ehemal
stolzen Alpenrepublik
Großvater Großvater du bist Pleite
na du hast bei steigenden Zinsen
langfristige Anleihen gekauft weißt du
nicht mal was eine Emissionsrendite ist
du Vollidiot
also ich habe mir Wärmepumpen Aktien
gekauft und bin jetzt reicher als Gott
du und der Ziegenpeter ihr zwei könnt
mich mal
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gar nicht mitgekriegt aber Heidi hat den
almögens heimgesteckt und lebt jetzt als
influencerin in Dubai
die Credit Swiss verbucht für 2022 einen
Verlust von unglaublichen 7,3 Milliarden
Franken und während die Schweizer Banken
auf sich vermutlich käsefondu gemacht
hat haben Kunden allein im letzten
Quartal 22 da über 100 Milliarden
abgezogen klarer Fall von Missmanagement
was sagen denn jetzt die Bosse wer ist
verantwortlich für dieses Desaster
schauen Sie
rückwärts zu schauen ist immer einfach
nachher sieht man da noch was wir für
eine Scheiße gebaut haben oder
auf Schweizerdeutsch klingt alles
niedlich die Kredit Suisse sammelt
Skandale wie andere Leute Briefmarken
ich sage nur Geldwäsche für die
bulgarische Mafia ist kein Witz oder für
irgendwelche shady Ölkonzerne Geldwäsche
gehört zu deren Kerngeschäft ne
umso lustiger meine Damen und Herren
dass ich die fast bankrotten Miss
Manager bis vorgestern trotzdem ihre
fetten Boni gönnen wollten ja bestimmte
Vergütungen werden nun vorläufig vom
Schweizer Staat eingefroren gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig bleibt das grundsätzliche
Boni Problem unsere EZB will die von ihr
kontrollierten Banken unter die Lupe
nehmen weil für erfolgsabhängige Prämien
oft zu große Risiken Zitat Ende
eingegangen werden warum weil Spaß macht
du zockst gern aber hast keinen Bock
mehr auf das lahme Monopoly mit all den
Regeln dann hol dir jetzt bonipoli das
geile Spiel bei dem es einfach immer
Geld regnet völlig egal was du würfelst
es gibt ständig fette Boni du gehst doch
nie ins Gefängnis denn du bist ja Banker
keiner verliert also gut außer natürlich
der doofe kleiner der sich
Finanzprodukte aufquatschen lässt das
ist ja voll
unfairo nein das ist
asoziale Spiel für Arschlöcher von 9 bis
ja
kein schönes Spiel aber man lernt eine
Menge
fakt ist seit 2008 werden europäische
Banken schon stärker reguliert in
manchen Punkten Stichwort höhere
Eigenkapitalquoten es braucht aber noch
mehr vor allem endlich die Trennung von
Investment und Geschäftsbanken fordern
Experten seit Jahren stattdessen hat
sich Christian Lindner aber noch im
Februar über zu strenge
Bankenregulierung in der EU beschwert
seitdem nennen sie ihn an der Börse nur
noch bangman
Zitat Lindner im angelsächsischen Raum
konnten Institute mehr Resilienz
entwickeln Schnitt auf die Pleite der
amerikanischen Silicon Valley Bank sehr
schlecht gealter der Satz sehr schlecht
was in den USA passiert das war übrigens
der erste Twitter Banken ran der
Menschheitsgeschichte
ich dachte wenn es irgendwo kompetente
Experten gibt dann ja wohl auf Social
Media fresh
der die Schweiz da ist die Credit Swiss
und die scheint den Kollaps kurz vor der
Tür zu haben es Crash wie Hunde ja da
fassen wir noch einer von hinten an den
Dispo Freunde ich flippe aus ja was
immer er nimmt ich will es auch
finanzinfluenza finfluencer das ist der
neue Traumberuf unsere netzreporterin
Larissa mich da seit kurzem auch mit
Larissa was lernen wir denn jetzt aus
der neuesten Bankenkrise ja also Herr
Oliver gut dass sie fragen weil ich gebe
ja online Seminare zum Thema Geldanlage
inzwischen seit fast ich glaube zwei
Tagen und ich kann nur sagen der Fisch
stinkt vom Schwanz ja und zwar nach
Fisch
die Menschen wissen einfach zu wenig
über ihre Finanzen es wird uns auch in
der Schule nicht beigebracht vor allem
wenn ich mit einem kleinen Kindern über
Aktien Rede und du meine Güte wirklich
sie wissen nichts trotzdem business man
trifft auf geballte Inkontinenz
also sie fordern Finanzkompetenz als
Schulfach ja natürlicher weil manche
Kids sind so dumm sie können Eurobonds
von Schokobons nicht unterscheiden ich
schwöre dabei ist es ganz einfach reich
zu werden ein Baby kann das und wie das
geht das könnt ihr alles nachlesen in
meinen neuen Ratgeber das Geheimnis von
Reichtum mehr Geld haben
ja aber wo kommt das Geld denn her
kriege ich bitte Sie auch nicht mal Geld
gibt's überall wie Strand am Meer ja
einfach mal out of the box denken ja
nicht immer warten bis der Prinz aus
Afrika die Milch schickt nein auch mal
von sich aus dem Prinz schreiben und
sagen ja eh überweis mir doch bitte mal
1000 €, ich schwöre damit rechnet er
nicht ja oder nächste geniale Idee wie
ich finde sie heißt
umgekehrter Enkeltrick also einfach
irgendwelche Kinder in der Nachbarschaft
anrufen und zu sagen hallo hier ist dein
liebe Omi ich hatte leider ein Unfall
und braucht ganz schnell 5000 € für die
Arztrechnung ja weil sonst sterblich und
du bist dann ja praktisch Schuld
das ist glaube ich kriminell oder oder
absoluter Insider Tipp für Real Cash
Flow und zwar in Baden-Baden da gibt es
ein voll schönes Haus es ist wie ein
Palast so edel und die haben das so ein
drehdings mit den Kugel und wenn dann
Rot kommt kriegt man achtung das
Doppelte ja und wenn dann noch mal rot
kommt wieder das Doppelte ein Casino
bitte unterbrechen Sie mich nicht ich
bin mitten in mein Online-Vortrag also
und wenn es wieder rot kommt noch mal
das doppelte und das macht ihr dann
einfach so lange bis ihr ich glaube so
drei Milliarden hat und damit kauft man
dann die Kredit Suisse und ist offiziell
to be back to fail also ähm zu dick und
bleibt zu gehen ja und dann fertig
Jackpot zwinker Smiley
wenn zwischendurch mal schwarz kommt
also das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ist
wirklich ein sehr konstruiert das Teil
und
man merkt hier ganz deutlich sie sind
nicht im Thema weil ich will doch nur
den jungen Zuschauern helfen weil viele
von den werfen ihr Leben weg und machen
ein Ausbildung oder wirklich noch
schlimmer wie studieren teilweise sogar
jahrelang ja in Deutschland gibt es aber
nur einen einzigen Weg zum rechten und
das ist Erben wer wirklich richtig viel
Geld zahlt in Deutschland kaum Steuern
und das kann man alles in meinem neuen
und zweiten Bestseller Buch lesen das
Geld liegt nicht auf der Straße aber
wenn du die Treppe ordentlich wohnst
liegt Oberbayern davor es kann so
einfach sein Alter
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig